je me rappelle en 2012 dans l'émission
phone dans une émission sur fun radio
canada s'est confié devrait avoir cet
extrait est à vous un secret il est
temps qu'ils surent vous jaws depuis des
années sans avoir réussi à vous faire
craquer et ça s'est jamais fait qu'adam
il a été très romantique 1 c'est
quelqu'un de très romantique et
aujourd'hui nous sommes très amis il ya
jamais eu un smack a fait écouter le
nouvel mama temps mettez moi tout nouvel
sait dans quelles chansons saynètes et
chansons c ou c dans laquelle nom
adresse et salage est mondiale et si tu
en as je te déteste pas du tout zapata
genre ça y est tu as essayé de me paie
chaud mais ça fait pas fait du tout mais
je te déteste une parenthèse peut-être
gp choses ne me brûle pas cap' adams ne
fume pas c'est pas les tuer si grand et
je suis tout petit non plus je suis tout
petit non non non tic tac
ils mangent pas petit tapis données non
ça c'est avec enrico macias les blondes
ça fait pour kddi les accords et lettres
n'ont roulé sur l'or
merci jonas et j'en ai assez de tu
blagues dont vous le dis il ya que veux
tu de moi
pas mal à revivre pour exister hors
sujet nos secrets je suis une tortue
dans sa chute avec une tortue ninja et
latigo c'est laquelle j'ai quelques
chansons parlent de cavalaire donc à
cette chanson il médite nous l'acquéreur
non mais après c'est largement inspiré
mais c'est là qu'elle ne brûle pas non
bah non il fume pas alors j'ai besoin ne
brûle pas en plus âgés 3g 3g trois
chances d'accord pas en cause une
parenthèse c'est une parenthèse c'est la
parenthèse bien mon chirurgien
tu me passes se dissout labo
[Rires]
il me passait au labo tu m'écoutes et tu
me réécoute la parenthèse je veux tout
savoir sur quelle maladie souffre sa
pointure weston l'accord son choix dans
les tic tac je veux tout savoir sur lui
pour décortiquer la parenthèse veut
savoir exactement ce qui s'est passé
entre ces deux là et s'il ya eu papa
dans maman merci et au sourire et vous
saurez également ce qui s'est passé
entre m adams et john johnatan loi
vivant je le saurai quoi qu'est ce qu'un
bon ça c'est fait wise
alors oui c'est une parenthèse oui